what's up everyone this is international
master Eric Rosen and welcome to another
video in this video I'd like to show a
very quick game I played just over a
week ago it was at the US Amateur teen
tournament and I was playing against
Cameron Tolliver if I'm saying that
correctly whose rating is just over 2000
and it was kind of a surprisingly quick
game given that I was black I played the
Queens gambit declined which isn't known
to be the most aggressive opening ever
and I won in 19 moves so I played some
aggressive kind of enterprising chess
and I'm hoping that viewers can kind of
learn learn a thing or two about how to
play aggressively from this game so the
game started out d4 and 906 c4 e6 right
c3 actually started out looking to go
perhaps into an Enzo Indian however one
of the main problems with an Enzo and I
played this opening a good number of
times over my career main drawback is
that there's a lot of a lot of responses
for whites and if I were to play this I
would have to have good knowledge of
what to do against every single response
with a three Queen c2 9 f3 f3 III Bishop
g5 these are all kind of playable lines
with different ideas for white and
normally if I'm playing someone who I
don't know and I don't know what their
opening rapper tour might be then I'll
usually stick with openings that I feel
more comfortable with now the nihms oh
is an opening that I use against players
who whose games I I've studied and and
know what they typically play but if I
don't know what my opponent will play
I'll usually just play d5 here and and
keep the game on my own turf so my
opponent played one of most common
variations here he took on d5 played
Bishop g5 i play c6 he plays Queen c2
and the point of Queen c2 is actually to
prevent Bishop f5 another main line here
for a white is to play e3 after which I
would have played Bishop
and we could have entered this line
after Queen f3 Bishop g6 take take take
take and this was a position I was more
than willing to go into because I've
played this a number of times before and
it's a sort of position which is
approximately equal but I think there's
there's chances for black especially
with the bishop pair and especially if
the position can open up so I wasn't too
concerned about that line however let's
go back to the game my opponent played
Queen c2 and I played a somewhat rare
move here instead of playing kind of
normal Bishop e7 and castling I decided
to be a bit more ambitious and I played
Knight a six which is a move which I've
actually prepared in the past and the
idea behind this move is twofold one I
want to perhaps play night before and
harass the Queen and another idea is to
play 97 96 and simply maneuver the
knight to useful square in the center so
if my opponent played a three here I
would have played 97 96 and reached some
some solid position however my opponent
played III and he kind of put me up to
the challenge of of whether I want to
play Knight before and I went ahead
attack the Queen and the point is I want
to kind of drive the Queen off this
diagonal so I can develop my Bishop to
f5 so he played the most normal-looking
move Queen B 1 and then if I don't have
my next move then this whole night a6
might be for idea probably makes no
sense my next move makes this possible I
played pawn g6 and the idea is setting
up Bishop to f5 and white is already in
kind of a awkward situation where he has
to figure out how exactly to deal with
the threat of Bishop f5 coming now
there's a couple of moves for white in
this position one of which I have very
very deep preparation against that move
being a3
and without getting too much into the
kind of details of this move I will say
that Bishop f5 is is a response and
afteri for things got very complicated
but I'll probably save this analysis for
another video because things get very
very complex I will say the the other
move here is queen d1 probably the best
move and if I play Bishop to f5 then
white can play rook c1 and what's
essentially happened is I can't really
exploit my setup any way further because
White has both d3 and c2 under control
and whites planning to play a3 next so
if this works happen I would play a 5
and then after a 396 and it would be a
game where I've kind of included this
weird move g6 but the idea for black now
is to play Knight C 76 like I mentioned
before probably Bishop e7 and Castle and
it would be a fairly dynamic position so
what happened the game was he played
pawn f3
I played h6 and I kick his Bishop back
and then I play Bishop f5 and what I'm
doing is basically forcing him to play
e4 there's really no other move here he
can play and when he plays e4 he's
opening up the center and making his
King a bit weaker and this is very
relevant to what happens in just a few
moves where the center is going to open
up and his King was going to be left
wide open so I take he takes and I take
on d4 and this is essentially a piece
sacrifice where I'm allowing him to
weigh no minor piece basically he takes
on f6 I take and he takes now he went
into this without too much thoughts and
he should note that he was flying very
quickly in the opening and the problem
with this is I think he he just made a
misjudgment he thought that perhaps that
he's up at peace he should have some
some good chances here it's a
maybe survived maybe even get the
advantage but the problem is that
White's position is terrible the only
good thing is white has an extra Knights
but there's so many bad things about
White's position mainly white is
completely behind in developments I mean
most pieces are still on the back rank
and secondly the the black pieces are
gonna come to life incredibly quickly
I'm ready to play Bishop c5 Castle
queenside and put my rooks on d8 and e8
the to open vials and meanwhile White's
development is going to be very slow
because it's not going to be easy for a
white to castle either way and the game
ended very very quickly I ended up
castling queenside he played 9 f3 I
played Bishop c5 and after I get kind of
a deal placement for my pieces it's not
entirely clear how white solves any of
the problems
he can't Castle kingside obviously
because my Bishop on c5 so he played the
move King f1 and now in this position I
think my next move allowed me to win the
game without really any further efforts
and I would encourage the viewers to
pause the video and try and come up with
the next move here for black and I will
say that the next move is not the
easiest move to find the blacks pieces
seem perfect but you want to look for a
way to improve your position further so
the move I played was Queen e7 with a
very simple idea of wanting to play
Queen e3 and maybe in the not so simple
idea of threatening Knight d5 and taking
advantage of the fact that his Knight is
tied down to defending the bishop so
after Queen e7 White's under serious
serious pressure I was actually
expecting him to play queen c1
preventing Queen e3 but allowing 95s
would be winning for black instead he
chose a very surprising move which okay
and in this case probably every move is
losing for whites but he played the very
strange-looking Knight g1 and then after
Queen e3 I guess his idea
to play tonight h3 defend f2 but then I
played rook t2 and after a short thing
he resigns seeing that ok there's pretty
much no defense to mate or or serious
loss of material for white so I hope
people can maybe draw a few lessons from
this game I think the most important
lesson is the fact that material isn't
always the most important factor in a
position and especially in this game the
position essentially centered around
development and attack and that was much
more valuable for black than material so
I hope people enjoyed this game feel
free if you have any questions leave
some some comment in the video and I'll
do my best respond also if you have any
suggestions for topics of future videos
you'd like to see covered feel free send
me a message or leave a comment and I
will see you in the next video